Due to the fact that they can’t move and
as such can’t sneak up on you, many people
never really think of trees as being dangerous.
As it turns out though, beyond the occasional
tree that kills a person by falling on them,
there’s also a tree out there so deadly
it has been dubbed “The Suicide Tree”.
But as you’ll soon see, “The Murder Tree”,
is just as apt a name.
Cerbera odollam is a small hardwood tree (see,
How Do They Differentiate Between Hardwood
and Softwood Trees?
really, that title sounds boring and obvious
but it’s actually not what you think and
is super fascinating; I promise…) that can,
under favourable conditions grow to around
10 metres in height and is endemic to India
and south-east Asia.
Despite its unassuming appearance, the tree
hides a deadly secret inside of the husk that
contains its seeds.
These seeds contain a cardiac glycoside called,
cerberin.
Cerberin is incredibly toxic in relatively
low dosages, often killing its victims within
a few hours, during which time they may suffer
crippling stomach pain, diarrhea, irregular
heart rhythm, vomiting and sometimes a splitting
headache.
Eventually, once enough of it accumulates
in your system, the cerberin will succeed
in completely inhibiting the cellular “sodium/potassium
pump” enzyme (Na+/K+-ATPase), screwing with
the heart’s electrical system and ultimately
stopping it dead, very similar to how lethal
injections in the United States work.
(See: How the Heart Works and Why Proper Sterilization
Procedures are Used During Lethal Injections)
And for reference, a single cerbera odollam
seed contains a lethal dose of cerberin for
a typical adult human.
Cerbera-OddloamWhile accidental ingestion
of the inner seed is not completely unheard
of, due to the fruit produced by the cerbera
odollam being edible, if a little bitter,
it is commonly used for murder and suicide
in Indian coastal towns which border the sort
of marshy swampland the tree likes to grow
in.
Exactly how many people are killed each year
due to someone having their food intentionally
spiked with cerbera odollam seeds isn’t
clear because the poison produced by it doesn’t
show up on normal toxicology reports, and
is relatively unknown in many regions of the
world.
This has led some experts, such as French
Toxicologist Yvan Gaillard, who published
the results of a decade long study on this
very topic in the Journal of Ethnopharmacology,
to describe the plant as being “perfect”
for murder.
You see, most toxicologists, even if they’ve
heard of the plant, will only test for cerberin
poisoning if there’s a strong suspicion
the victim consumed something containing it
prior to their death, because testing for
cerberin poisoning is rather costly and requires
the use of “high-performance liquid chromatography
coupled with mass spectrometry” to detect
with any degree of certainty- something that
is not an option in many regions anyway.
Of course, those toxicologists who haven’t
heard of it would never know to check.
Because of this, the amount of deaths caused
by cerbera odollam poisoning is uncertain.
That said, based on the documented instances
that are known (which likely make up a small
percentage of the actual total), the plant
is responsible for at least a death per week
in the South Indian state of Kerala alone,
where the plant grows wild and in abundance
and is responsible for an estimated 50% of
plant poisoning cases annually in the region.
You might wonder why a person being poisoned
with such a seed wouldn’t taste it, given
its bitter flavour, but the seeds can easily
be masked by putting them into a dish containing
something like chilies that are prevalent
in Indian cuisine.
The taste can also be masked with sugar, and
the vast majority of suicides committed via
ingestion of the seeds is done by removing
the seed from the outer husk, then crushing
and mixing it with raw cane sugar.
“Just a spoon full of sugar helps the medicine
go down” and all that.
Not the most pleasant way to die, but given
it’s freely available in places like Kerala,
and has a relatively certain outcome, it remains
extremely popular.
Interestingly, with the limited data we do
have (including suicides and murders), it’s
noted that 75% of people who die via ingesting
the cerbera odollam seeds are women.
Researchers at the Laboratory of Analytical
Toxicology in La Voulte-sur-Rhône speculate
that this massive gender discrepancy is because
the plant is being used to poison newly married
wives “who do not meet the exacting standards
of some Indian families“.
However, beyond the murders, young women are
also statistically much more likely to use
the cerbera odollam seeds to commit suicide;
such was the case in May of 2015 when four
young girls consumed cerbera odollam seeds
as part of a suicide pact after being abused
at an athletic training camp.
That said, it should be noted that in the
Western world, while about four men will commit
suicide for every one woman, nearly three
times as many women as men will attempt to
kill themselves.
If the popular method of suicide in the Western
world was using something like cerbera odollam
seeds where death is almost certain, it could
potentially skew those tragic numbers significantly
to be somewhat more inline with the Laboratory
of Analytical Toxicologies data for Kerala,
India.
Whatever the case, the prominent use of this
plant in suicides and murders has led to local
governments trying to find new uses for this
natural resource.
Particularly in impoverished areas, if the
seeds have marketable uses, it’s literally
money growing on trees for any of the populace
who wants it, making the seeds less readily
available as they’re harvested en masse-
so less death and more money in the local
economy.
Towards this end, in recent years the seeds
have begun being harvested for use in various
products like bio-insecticides and rat poison,
among other things.
In Kerala, where the plant is responsible
for more deaths than anywhere else on Earth,
locals can earn a decent living dehusking
the plant with their bare hands in various
processing yards across the state.
We bet lunch hour at those places is really
tense…
You’ll note that we said that ingesting
the seeds is a “relatively” certain way
to die.
Modern medical science being pretty amazing,
there are methods to counteract the poison’s
effects.
For instance, a 51 year old woman in Maryland
decided ingesting the seeds of the cerbera
odollam would be a good way to shuffle off
this mortal coil, so she ordered some on eBay,
ground them up and ate them.
However, she must have changed her mind after
the fact, because when the effects of the
poison started kicking in and it got real,
she rushed herself to the emergency room,
at which point her heart rate was a scant
30 beats per minute.
The medical staff were stumped.
They at first thought she’d been the victim
of digoxin poisoning, which has similar effects,
but the labs said no.
With death looming, she finally admitted what
she’d done and the doctors decided to try
administering twenty vials of digoxin immune
FAB at a whopping $500-$700 per vial.
It worked and she later walked out of the
hospital with a clean bill of health, hopefully
receiving some counseling or other help to
go along with what the miracle workers in
the hospital did.
(Note: The suicide hotline number in the United
States is: 1-800-273-8255, and in the UK it’s
+44 (0) 8457 90 90 90.)
In the 19th century, the fruit of the cerbera
odollam was used in Madagascar (a place it
is also known to grow) to test a person’s
innocence.
Those committed of a crime were sometimes
required to eat the fruit to prove their innocence
and if they survived they were free to go.
Because a single seed of the fruit is enough
to kill, this invariably led to a lot
of “guilty” individuals.